Before we get started, let's discuss
some of the necessary technologies you
should be familiar with in order to
get the most out of this course.
Most importantly, you should have
a basic understanding of Python coding.
If you're comfortable creating classes,
writing methods, and
understand inheritance,
you are in good shape for this course.
Knowledge of SQL statements such as
insert into, select, update, and
delete will also be a useful
skill in this course.
I will also assume you're
very comfortable reading and
writing HTML code.
CSS and JavaScript won't be necessary
to complete the activities, but
are helpful for creating a polished,
presentable final project.
Knowing your way around
the Unix command line and
being able to navigate through the file
system is also going to come in handy.
If you are unfamiliar or would like
to brush up on any of these topics,
please refer to the instructor notes for
some helpful links to classes and
other references.
For ease of configuration, and
installation, I strongly recommend using
a Vagrant machine for this course.
Vagrant allows you to create a virtual
machine on your computer so that you can
program without worrying about affecting
your computer's current configuration.
I have provided you a Vagrant file
with all of the necessary software
already installed.
A link to installing this Vagrant file
is provided in the instructor notes.
Once you successfully run vagrant up and
vagrant ssh, you're ready to keep going.